SCP-096 Vs SCP-272. Can the Old Iron Nail
finally be the thing that nails down SCP-096,
the sinister, mass-murdering Shy Guy?
The Nail has the ability to pin a person’s
shadow to the ground, potentially leaving
them stuck there forever. If the shadow is
altered by changing light, it can lead to
horrific bodily contortions, and attempting to
attack the Nail also leads to a horrific death.
Because 096 only attacks people that see its
face, it would never attack the nail itself.
It’s also unlikely that it would be killed
by a shadow-bashing due to its incredibly
durable nature. However, the truly compelling
question is also one we don’t have the answer to:
If 272 was pinning 096’s shadow to
the ground, and someone saw its face,
would it be pinned in place? Let us
know what you think in the comments.